but the pm must be feeling it the
pressure building over rising omicron
rates so close to christmas
another record day for cases and now
someone has died with the new variant
the idea that this is somehow a milder
version of the virus i think that's
something we need to set on one side and
just recognize the sheer
pace at which it accelerates
on a visit to a vaccination center in
london the pm lay in bear how fast that
pace is by tomorrow omicron will make up
the majority of all infections in the
capital meaning 12 days before christmas
the pm can't rule out more restrictions
the best thing we can do to protect
ourselves protect our country
and ensure that we have as normal a
christmas as possible is to get boosted
now the question i asked though was can
you rule out more restrictions and it
seems you can't because you didn't so
you can't rule out more restrictions
before christmas
let me just say on that that throughout
the pandemic beth i've been a great
pains to stress to the public that we we
have to watch where it where the
pandemic is going we we take whatever
steps are necessary
but in the commons his mps in revolt the
health secretary sent out to corral the
conservative back benches ahead of a
crucial vote on plan b tomorrow
i know we are weary
but it's on all of us to pick up to step
up and do some phenomenal work once
again to play our part and to get
boosted now
but the mood angry mp's patience with
this pm worn out
more than 70 mps minded to vote against
the prime minister refused three times
this morning to rule out further
restrictions being taken before
christmas can i have an assurance
that this house will be recalled to
debate and vote on those measures what
does my right honourable friend say to
my constituent who says she is now less
afraid of covid than she is of intrusive
and incoherent government regulations
i'm concerned a bit about the mixed and
heavy messaging coming from uh the
government uh the
unintended consequences of that can be
dire a pm who has to rely on labour to
pass critical new coveted rules kirsten
tonight addressed the nation himself
we will always support measures designed
to protect public health
that includes the measures in plan b
we are a patriotic party
and it's our patriotic duty to vote for
these measures
the message to get a booster heard loud
and clear by those waiting at st
thomas's a stone's throw from parliament
you only have to look at this cue for
boosters to get a sense of the national
anxiety now building people are waiting
up to five hours to get a job desperate
to protect themselves and their family
christmas and over the river the prime
minister is now under acute pressure his
mps are in open rebellion his number 10
is engulfed in scandal and his public
support is plummeting as he struggles to
control this galloping covid crisis
a pm whose own actions has left his
authority his government badly shaken
the week ahead could be even tougher
than the last holding out hope that the
booster programme can save the day beth
rigby sky news westminster